[Music]
let's go to lauren and angola what's up
lauren how we doing
pretty good thanks for taking my phone
call of course you got it thanks for
calling what's up
uh so i guess uh overview of like me i
am a pregnant mom with three children
four and under and they
just i stopped there
wow
wow
whoa
when are you uh what do you do
i'm due the end of september
so you'll have four under five
five and under here
yep
wow
i love it though they're no i'm i i i am
i'm in awe of you i'm not even i'm not
making jokes i'm not making fun of i am
just absolutely in awe of you
congratulations fantastic thank you so
much wildness very cool okay so
four under five
four under five have health issues and
my children have some health issues and
stuff too and my husband
works all the time okay and he's almost
never home and so
i guess one of my questions is like
how do i navigate knowing like what
what is actual needs and what is okay to
say my needs are to my husband
when i know he worked so hard for us but
at the same time i feel like there's got
to be a balance of rest and quality time
mixed in there and like i understand
like we have a farm and he works
construction and some other things
but like i understand that farm life can
be challenging and stuff and i we knew
what we were getting to where we did
this but at the same time i feel like i
get the leftovers of him
um
man there's a lot of places to start
here what
why do you think
who told you
that your needs
have to be filtered through
all these different filters that you put
on them
i i think a big part of it is i've
always been the
sick kid that always caused money to
cost money and took up way much more
time and everyone always had to work
harder for me
so it's a lot of like trying to be as
less of a burden as i am
so if nobody's ever told you this before
and i'm the first person to tell you
this i'm sorry
hopefully other people have told you
this
but you're not a burden
and respectfully i'm going to ask you to
never say those words out loud again
because they're not true
yeah it's
it's like a constant struggle in my life
yeah
what what's happening
and my husband
he said what what health issues
i
mean they don't have a label on it
because it's really confusing but it's
kind of similar to like celiacs and
crohn's yes but it just
just chronic ideas
and headaches okay and um and like crazy
severe allergies that are like step down
from anaphylactic okay
so hey i got a great idea you should
move to a farm
oh it's it's honestly a huge help
because is it really because of all my
food allergies like we raise grass-fed
beef organic fed chicken non-gmo pork
and it's like helps because we don't
have to buy any of our meat okay all
right
um my husband's just not great at
balancing life and family and work
yes
so
you and i could go down a rabbit hole
together that i think would be a
distraction from the casual listener
so i will say this this way and i feel
pretty strongly about it
number one
a mother surrounded a mother who's
become a human jungle gym which is what
you are right
can be
dreadfully and sometimes
frighteningly alone
lonely okay definitely that's number one
loneliness
a woman who loves her husband your
husband's a good guy right
oh yeah he's awesome pretty amazing okay
and he's working his butt off he's not
hiding or running he's not like sitting
down
he's working his butt off okay
um and he's probably trying to give you
the life that you all talked about
having together right
and you're trying to give him the life
that you all talked about having
together
yeah yeah and now we're in a dance right
um
you love somebody who's just at the edge
of your fingertips
that you see just in time for him to
fade into a mist of sleep and right when
you open your eyes he's getting up to
walk out the door and get back at it
yep
loneliness is such a bio dysregulator
and it disrupts every part of your
physical body
and so what i want to challenge you with
is if you are paying as close attention
to your diet as you do
and you are trying to create a less
inflammatory state
inside of you
yeah
the first place i would start
is with other people
not the dream
and i know that's hard to say out loud
so can you explain what you mean by that
yes
you are cashing in
relationally
you've moved out to a farm
you are missing
your other half literally
for this dream
and what i want to show you is this
dream is costing you in your health
in your
psychology in your emotional regulation
and it is causing your body to
eat itself from the inside
out okay
and what's keeping this thing going is
your dream and my guess is i can sit
down with your husband who's in year one
or year two or year three of working 20
hour days trying to keep this dream
going
pretty much since he was probably 16.
okay and working like this i have hung
out and loved and gone to church with
and been friends with
farmers who were very very old
and they left it all on the field
literally
right
and so the question i want y'all to ask
is
is your dream worth your health
is your dream worth your family
is is this life you're building
worth where you're headed
and so to answer your original question
is
your needs are always valid
and your needs are going to get in the
way if you will and i hate to use that
language but they're going to be
different than this cool picture that
y'all have together
like me and my wife
i'm making this up but if we have some
beautiful dream house that we want to
build in the mountains
and then i break my leg and my leg has
to
be amputated and i don't have wheelchair
access
then the dream is gonna have to be
different
see what i'm saying yeah and it's not
because i'm a burden it's because life
happened it just is and now we do
something different right
and so
your needs count always
i would say um in fact i'm working on a
new book right now
and the the working chapter so usually
what happens is i write like a nerd and
then i let people read it and they're
like we don't know what you're talking
about so the working title of this
chapter is the biology of secrets
ultimately if you've got needs that
you're not communicating you're keeping
secrets and ultimately secrets from the
person you love ends up being a really
fancy way of saying you're being
dishonest
fair yeah
yeah okay
so i think it's really really important
that you sit down and say here's what i
need i need you
and i would rather have you than this
thing that we're trying to do
that's it's i don't know that's like
kind of my fear i hate being the reason
to mess things up
you're not like i love i love our dreams
and i i feel like okay can i be can i be
super mean can i be super mean and not
mean whatever you want being direct
you can mess up your health you can mess
up your interpersonal relationship with
your children you can mess up your
marriage and keep this farm
or
you can choose to be whole
you can reimagine what your marriage is
going to look like
you can
be a
solid piece for
four under five
and then y'all can figure out what's
after that you see what i'm saying like
you're putting the wrong you're putting
the u-haul before the truck
yeah
and you're trying to push it on the road
it's like hard for me to think about
changing it because it's my whole
husband's life
and yeah i i i reject that
you are your husband's life
yeah and those kids are your husband's
life
he's doing this stuff in service of
y'all
yeah
so here's something that happened in my
life
um
you've probably i don't know if you read
the book my book or you've listened the
show at all um you've probably heard of
when i needed to i i was working at
university it's time for me to go like i
was an anxious mess to spun out
um we ultimately took a 70 000 household
income pay cut to leave that city and to
go somewhere else we didn't make that
much money it was devastating
financially for us okay
um it's not like we were making 300
grand and we like we had to suffer
through making 230 like we it was tough
and
the part of that story i don't tell
is that in that gap when we were leaving
there was a very real opportunity to
become a vice president
and i was all in
and my wife sat me down for one of the
first times in our marriage and this was
the beginning of us learning to
re-communicate to communicate anyway
and she said please don't
i need you
and it was enough that she felt like if
i go go do this new job
it might be it
and so it was that moment and i'm gonna
be honest with you i was pretty upset i
was mad it's all i ever wanted was to be
a vice president at in this job at this
particular place but that's all i wanted
been working for that for a long time
and i got pissed off and i kind of like
him through a hissy fit because i was
acting like a child like an immature
brat
and now that i look back i cannot tell
you how grateful i am that she spoke her
needs out loud
i feel like that's kind of like what
happened to us just last week
oh
i'm not good at speaking my needs and my
husband is not used to me speaking my
needs or just assumed i did and i
finally said
i couldn't do something that he really
wanted to do
and kind of shocked him
because he wanted to go on this big trip
over the weekend and i'm like okay like
i trust you as my husband but if we go
on this trip
you realize like i have to do all these
things and i'm probably going to be
emotional wreck afterwards because i'm
going to be worn out
which lowers my immune system and the
kids i'm going to have to watch them the
entire time because it's not a space
atmosphere
and but he
he wanted to do that but then i got sick
so
and that was probably
i'm speaking out of turn here because
i'm not a medical doctor but that was
probably your body saying if you're not
going to stop this madness i will
yeah i feel like it was
god trying to give them
a hint
it might have been but it could have
just been your body being exhausted and
worn out
here's a cool thing
and i say cool because it's going to
involve tears and it's going to involve
frustration and it's going to involve
practicing and trying new things that
y'all have never done before
you are going to have to create space
for your husband to
think for a season that you have not
been telling him the truth
and it hurts
even though you haven't been telling him
how you actually feel or what you're
experiencing to the fullest extent
because you're trying to protect him
he has been working to the fullest
extent to try to honor you
and there's gonna come a collision there
okay expect it it's gonna happen okay
yeah
what needs to happen is
he still has i've worked really really
really really really hard and now we
have a four day weekend or a three-day
weekend let's drive eight hours for
seven hours of fun and drive eight hours
back
this is super common when people have
young kids
one person generally is like well these
kids have to eat
and i'm the chief fuel source for two of
them and one of them just rocket
diarrhea's everywhere like you know i
mean like somebody thinks through it and
the other one just has like let's go to
the lake dude
and
so here's what we have to do we have to
completely reimagine life
the life y'all had before does not exist
anymore it's over
yep
the crazy farm life where he'd come work
and he'd come home smelling a little bit
but it's kind of hot and kind of sexy
and you're like oh there's my farmer
that world is over
right now
it's we got three kids another one on
the way
i'm i i still think he's sexy but you
should probably shower because i need
you to help put the kids to bed right it
just looks different now
and we have to reimagine what this looks
like
we have to build a new world because if
you keep trying to drag
the past with you into the present it
causes resentment and then people start
doing stupid stuff when they resent each
other
yeah and you're going to resent him
continuing to ask and he doesn't really
know the full extent because you're not
telling him the truth
and he's going to resent you because he
thinks you're just like you become a
burden and you're not a burden but
that's the way you're acting and that's
the way it projects out into the world i
think that's the main reason why i i
i know i'm bad about like thinking
things aren't necessarily needs because
i'm always trying to not be a problem
and so i think like i don't know he just
actually introduced me to your show just
like two weeks ago
and well here we are
the most problematic thing you can do is
not tell the truth
yeah
it's not been intentional i know i
realize i know that i'm not and i'm
saying it mean and direct like that on
purpose okay i know you haven't been
lying to him
um but you haven't been telling him the
full extent
and by hedging like i don't want him to
fully understand how tough things are or
i can't do it like i used to or i don't
want to do it like i used to want to do
it or we talked
for 10 years about our farm what it was
going to look like and we were going to
have all this healthy foods and we've
watched all the youtube clips and all
and now i kind of just want to move into
a five-bedroom house in a suburb
and have neighbors and people i can go
get eggs and sugar from without having
to go to the chicken coop with two kids
strapped to my back like
life changes
the only thing you're doing right now is
he feels that gap
of
of you're not being transparent with him
you're not speaking your needs he feels
that gap and he thinks that gap is his
fault
and so he's going to do the only thing
he knows how to do which is work harder
and longer
yeah am i right
yeah i mean i feel like i don't know
maybe it's just a guy thing but if he
can't accept my
problem then it's just
yeah it frustrates them and he works
harder that's right and your what
ultimately will happen is
he will
recognize in short order
he's better at the farming stuff than he
is at the husbanding stuff
he's better at the farming stuff than he
is at the kids stuff and he'll spend
even more time there because that's
where he feels
efficacious that's where he feels like
he knows what he's doing
and that happens with attorneys it
happens with people who run fast food
restaurants i'm just better at work it
happens here
i'm not very good at this show but you
should see me try to husband i'm not
good at that either and so there's some
days i'm better at just reading articles
and thinking of ways to talk about
anxiety than i am
sitting at a kitchen table listening to
my daughter telling me about dragon
turtles that you know that eat
i don't know i don't i still don't know
what we're talking about
i don't know how to do that and so it's
just like i'm gonna go get my
computer out and read another article
because i know how to do that
and i've got to learn to lean into the
discomfort and i can only do that when
i'm tethered into my wife and we are
connected connected so it's time for a
truth-telling time and the way i would
pitch this um you're new to the show
you and your husband need to get
somebody to watch those kids all 17 of
them and you all need to have a half day
retreat or a full day retreat and walk
away and make three columns
what we dreamed about
here let's be honest about what we
wanted we wanted a big huge farm with a
big huge farmhouse and we wanted kids
running around everywhere we wanted
these things
and then the middle column is here's
reality my body's falling apart
we wanted seven kids i'm pregnant with
number four and i'm starting to get sick
a lot
and i'm having to feed two of these kids
and the third one is still like here's
where life is
and that third column is going to be
we got to reimagine what was and we've
got to have a new vision moving forward
it might be that you stay at the farm
but you have to hire some help and it
might be that you stay at the farm but
he commits to coming home at five
o'clock every day and not going back out
to run hay in the dark
it might be fill in the blank any number
of those things that you need help four
days a week with bedtime
with bath time with breakfast time with
those things you need those first and
then we're gonna backfill work on the
back end or you're gonna have to hire a
housekeeper whatever it looks like
here's what this looks like moving
forward for us
and my promise to you is he's going to
exhale too
just like i did
your needs always count his due to and
the magic of being married is y'all
figure out how can i do whatever it
takes to meet your needs
well you're doing everything you can do
to meet my needs
and that often means doing different
things and either one of us would have
cooked up and that my friend is the
beauty of it all